[Music]
in the beginning Santa was a saint Saint
Nicholas and he dressed like the Pope
and had a long staff and a big habit he
would go around and leave sacks of money
and fireplace stockings and leave gold
coins and empty shoes like around then
the Dutch changed him into some kind of
God like Odin and he stopped wearing
pants he wore a crown and grew a really
long beard like Gandalf he didn't
deliver presents on Christmas he
delivered them whenever he felt like it
which wasn't very often because he was
too busy sitting in his throne because
they called him the Lord a hundred or so
years later after he got tired of
sitting around he shrink and became an
elf and his beard shrink too he started
smoking and he gained weight and he
traded his sheets for some furs but he
was the first Santa to carry a large
sack of toys that he would drop down
chimneys on Christmas Eve
then one day he must have gotten tired
of doing things by himself
so he hired a trained ears to help him
they flew around dragging him in a
sleigh and he smoked his pipe and threw
presents down chimneys then he got
fatter and he decided it was too cold so
he put on pants and married mrs. Claus
so she could cook him hot meals then
Santa joined the army and made lots of
appearances and malls and coke
commercials so he could pay for his elf
workers on the North Pole and nowadays
he's still around and he will always be
there waiting for the time that he can
bring you gifts and cheer on the
Christmas time of year and thats how st.
Nicholas became Santa
[Music]